c'était une réouverture très attendu
après deux mois de pause dans ce centre
commercial de dijon 110 des 138
boutiques ont levé leur rideau
les clients étaient impatients
aujourd'hui je suis venu faire mais
comme ses pieds aussi venu voir un petit
peu les magasins qui ont pu ouvrir ou
pas pour faire un petit tour pour
prendre plaisir à regarder les
nouveautés chi tellement contente
d'appareils et magasins de textile qui
courent ça manque beaucoup et pourtant
c'est cette image qui a choqué hier des
commentaires par centaines pour dénoncer
ces consommateurs entrant dans un
magasin sont respectés la fameuse
distanciation sociale de quoi raviver le
virus la deuxième vague va arriver
réseau économique mais pas du tout
sanitaire qui a dit que les choses
changeraient après le confinement
rien ne changera jamais dans le centre
commercial le port du masque n'est pas
obligatoire il n'y a aucun filtrage pour
limiter le nombre de personnes dans la
galerie une signalisation ont été mises
en place pour tenter d'imposer un sens
de circulation
mais elle apparaît difficile à faire
respecter ce commerçant s'inquiète
forcément des flèches au sol c'est pas
suffisant pour
pour que les gens respectent un parcours
donc non ça rentre par les sorties ça
sort par les entrées c'est normal c'est
normal des perdus dans des conditions
comme ça pas 100%
les autorités invoquent nécessaire
reprise économique
mais la décision peut paraître étonnante
quand des petits restaurants eux doivent
rester fermés le risque d'interaction
entre entre les personnes le risque de
propagation du virus et de façon
générale plus élevés dans des espaces de
restauration dans des espaces barre dans
des lieux de congrès que dans des
espaces plus vastes plus ouvert où on
peut peut-être aussi davantage écarter
les gens et les amener à ne pas se
côtoyer reste à savoir si cela se
vérifie le samedi la journée du pic
d'affluence avec plus de trente mille
visiteurs en moyenne